on le dit dans mon oreillette il ya les
acteurs il est rond wolschheim a dit on
me dit dans mon oreillette il ya deux
deux jeunes hommes bien connus sur d8 là
qui sont de passage dans les locaux qui
souhaiteraient venir nous rejoindre vous
êtes d'accord pourquoi je demande
d'accueillir grégoire ludig et david
marsais n'est pas le machin
eric
et
et cyril arrive tu dis on nous ferait
bien entraînés tout il ya l'art est fait
se passe très bien on veut pas la gâcher
les gars sympa ouais mais vous aimez
bien les filles avec des cheveux un peu
long parce que si lille sera pas là ce
soir
ouais parce qu'en fait c'est moi qui
fais les émissions ça sans s'exposer
on nous dit ce sont les gars
le sang
les coûts
marçais bonsoir
en plus d'installer s'il vous plaît
sa démission comme ça moi la forme
d'émissions comme ça répondait bien non
on est très très bien tu allais à non
non
alors oui c'est que j'aime bien alors
les garçons vous pensez que cyril était
là mais en fait c'est moi ce soir c'est
pas grave ça vous plaît quand même oui
un peu mieux même peut-être si la
réponse dépendra d'eux si je fais la
promo ou pas de hockey ce que c'est mais
que alors il ya un dvd
ouais palmashow sémard moins présente
very bad blagues saisons 1 et 2 le
coffret avec dan martin julie n'est pas
là ce soir et la base qu'est ce qu'on
veut c'est mieux je suis bien c'est
super c'est génial que ce soit mal à
complètement voir un extrait voilà un
mec saisir c'est génial c'est génial
c'est top 5
tu vois la prothèse son oubli prince des
princes c'est nous nan sans déconner
mais ni service terme [ __ ]
mais non non non moi c'est sûr que
princesse bon c'était pas une vocation d
les bulles ah ouais tu veux faire quoi
faits avait fait état des pouvoirs tu
voles c'est comme un pioche est aux
[ __ ] la française ménages aux toilettes
c'est que c'est un p dépend au routeur
pierre pierrot un répit quand ils paient
commun pourquoi tu prends pour la peine
quand peter pan mais c'est bravo bravo
ya plein de gaz aussi dans il ya
florence foresti pascal légitimus
christophe lambert wei li sé moun mon
père je crois il shoote dans mon papa
est dedans très familial vers les boss
wayne a passé le ses saisons 1 et 2
ouais alors en fait c'est le meilleur
des dix derrière diminuer le meilleur de
la saison 1 et 2 dans ce coffret 86
sketches sans blague mais même les
questions sont chouettes franchement la
saison 3 pourrait y avoir valérie benaïm
mais c'est prévu et dure tout le pâté
non pour être là peut faire la jeune
premier mais oui je m'en fous moi c'est
ouais applaudissements nourris sous
plafond
vite